we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p here's a question about
2024
hey david my name is steve i'm calling
from san diego california please i just
wanted to drop my two cents on who's
better
desantis or trump right who's worse i
guess
i think it's trump i think desantis
obviously
like you say he he probably could do
more damage
policy-wise just because
he's not
so
crazy yes
but but
he
i think trump would do more damage to
our institutions
long-term and short-term just destroying
democracy i just can't understand
or i can't fathom
seeing trump in office without the
possibility of him looking forward to
having an answer to the voters again
yeah i i understand the point that the
caller is making
but i actually still think that by
virtue of being less cartoonishly unable
to get anything done
in the net
desantis would be worse than trump i i
still i still think that but i'm open to
having my mind changed we've got a great
bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com we'll talk
about the twitter elon musk deal
evaporating we'll talk about california
starting to make its own insulin and we
will talk about the euro dollar parity
that has been reached for the first time
in 20 years and i have no plans to take
advantage of it that's for sure a sign
up at jointpakman.com we'll see you on
the bonus show